I am not a Muslim and I'll prove
it there you have it I'm not a Muslim
and yet I can say with a straight face
there are some amazing verses in the
Quran and some of them may even come
from God but David if Muhammad's a false
prophet doesn't that mean everything he
said was a lie from Satan no false
prophets don't come with all lies if
they did their followers wouldn't be
able to say but David how can Reverend
pyramid Moonbeam be a false prophet when
he says so many things I agree with see
that's why I trust him when he tells me
I need to let him bang my wife and that
I have to drink this
Kool-Aid false prophets say all kind
kind of things that are true and all
kinds of things that people agree with
it makes them more believable but with
Muhammad there's something else at work
you can actually follow his true claims
like a trail of breadcrumbs and this
Trail leads you somewhere very specific
I'm about to take you there so whether
you're a Muslim or a non-muslim you're
about to understand the Quran like
you've never understood it before
guaranteed
by the way are you familiar with these
exploding security paint packs or die
packs that Banks use to catch robbers
you're a bank teller and a robber shows
up and says fill this bag with money and
you do but you also toss in a paint pack
disguised as a bundle of bills which
blows up after he leaves and covers him
in some bright colored paint allowing
police to identify him as the bank
robber he is I leave behind
speaking of robbers 14 centuries ago a
caravan robber in Arabia robbed more
than just Caravans he robbed religions
he robbed their teachings and their most
important figures but suppose that while
Muhammad was robbing Christianity the
almighty tossed in a few paint packs
that are still blowing up in Muhammad's
face allowing us to identify him as the
religion robber he is
why would we think the Quran contains
security paint packs from god let's go
through three different kinds of Quran
verses that even non-muslims can agree
with and then we'll see which ones are
the paint packs first the Quran contains
a lot of verses about natural theology
the Quran draws attention to different
features of the world and says that
there signs that point to God for
instance there are two verse 164 indeed
indeed in the creation of the heavens
and the earth and the variation of the
night and the day and the ships that run
upon the sea with what benefits Mankind
and the water God sends down from the
sky whereby he revives the Earth after
its death scattering all manner of Beast
therein and the shifting of the Winds
and the clouds subdued between the sky
and the Earth are surely signs for a
people who understand here the the Quran
invites readers to reflect on how the
world seems like it's put together for
our benefit we should be filled with
gratitude towards our creator you can
agree with verses like this even if
you're not a Muslim but is there any
reason to think that these verses came
from God no lots of people do natural
theology second the Quran responds to
critics and Skeptics and some of the
responses are surprisingly good in Surah
22:5 for example the Quran answers
people who mock the idea of the
Resurrection both the Bible and the
Quran claim that God will raise people
from the dead at the resurrection some
critics mock belief in the resurrection
by saying seriously you think God is
going to put you back together after you
decompose listen to the quran's
response oh mankind if you are inou out
concerning the resurrection remember we
created you from dust then from a drop
then from a blood clot then from a lump
of Flesh formed and unformed that we may
make clear for you and we cause what we
will to remain in the wombs for a term
appointed then we bring you forth as an
infant then that you may reach maturity
and some are taken in death and some are
consigned to the most abject life so
that after having known they may know
nothing and thou seest the Earth
desiccated but when we send down water
upon it it stirs and swells and produces
every delightful kind there are multiple
responses packed into this verse at the
end the Quran points out that you can
look around and see things dying no rain
for a few months all you see is a desert
waste then it starts rainning and
everything Springs to life sort of like
the
resurrection before that the Quran
refers to different stages of
development you're in the womb then
you're an infant then you're mature then
you're dead the idea here is why is it
so absurd to think that there's another
stage after death but the most
interesting response is at the beginning
of the verse you think it's crazy that
God can put you back together
have you thought about how you were put
together in the first place God created
you from dust then from a drop of seen
then from a blood clot then from a lump
of Flesh why do you doubt God's ability
to bring you back to life when he's the
one who already gave you life sadly the
dawa guys ruin this verse by trying to
argue that it contains miraculous
scientific knowledge it doesn't it's
actually wrong you were never a blood
clot but that's not the point of the
verse the Quran isn't giving miraculous
scientific knowledge it's giving a
common but flawed 7th Century view of
embryonic development you can change
this to a modern View and the point is
still valid you know that you formed
from tiny little things like a sperm and
an egg but you think the resurrection is
silly I actually like that response
but is there any reason to think it's
from God no it's a good point just don't
ruin it by pretending there's some
miraculous scientific Insight here third
now for the fun part the Quran is filled
with claims about Jesus and the Bible
but even when the Quran is trying to
portray Jesus as a mere prophet of Islam
it can't help but portray him as much
more than a prophet of Islam consider
Surah 4:
171 oh people of the book do not
exaggerate in your religion nor utter
anything concerning God save the truth
verily the Messiah Jesus is the Messiah
Jesus Son of Mary was only a messenger
of God see he was only a messenger and
his
word wait Jesus is the word of God the
speech of God which he committed to to
Mary and a spirit from him Jesus is a
spirit from God so believe in God and
His Messengers and say not three refrain
it is better for you God is only one God
glory be to him that he should have a
child unto him belongs whatsoever is in
the heavens and whatsoever is on the
earth and God suffices as a guardian
notice there are a bunch of criticisms
against the deity of Christ and The
Trinity here and yet right in the middle
of all these attacks on Christian
theology the Quran calls Jesus a spirit
from God and the word of God Christians
know why Jesus is called the word of God
John 1 in the beginning was the word and
the Word was with God and the Word was
God he was with God in the beginning
through him through through the word all
things were made without him nothing was
made that has been made in him was life
and that life was the light of all
mankind the light shines in the darkness
and the Darkness has not overcome it and
verse 14 the word became flesh and made
his dwelling among us we have seen his
glory the glory of the one and only son
who came from the father full of grace
and
truth see what I mean the Quran
proclaims Jesus was just a prophet just
a prophet just a
prophet and he's the word of God well
what does it mean for Jesus to be the
word of God the Quran doesn't explain so
you have to go outside the Quran to find
out what means for Jesus to be the word
of God and that's where you find out who
Jesus really is and that Muhammad was a
false
prophet according to the Quran Jesus was
just another prophet in a long series of
prophets also according to the Quran
Jesus is the word of God and a spirit
from God he's the Messiah he was born of
a virgin he was sinless he lived the
most miraculous ulous life in history he
preached when he was a baby he created
the same way God
creates Jesus is completely unique in
the Quran and he's greater far greater
than
Muhammad why why is Jesus so much
greater than Muhammad in the Quran it
makes no
sense then there are all the verses
where the Quran affirms the inspiration
the preservation and the authority of
the Jewish and Christian scriptures our
Muslim friends tell us that the gospel
was corrupted there's not one word in
the entire Corran about the gospel being
corrupted Surah 3 says that God sent
down the Torah and the gospel a four
time as a guidance to mankind sah 7: 157
refers to those who follow the Messer
the unlettered prophet whom they find
inscribed in the Torah and the go gospel
that is with them Jews and Christians
have the Torah and The Gospel According
to the Quran in Surah
5:47 Allah commands let the people of
the Gospel judge by what God has sent
down therein Allah commands Christians
to judge not by the Quran but by what he
has sent down in the gospel then he
gives Christians this warning who
whosoever judges not by that which God
has sent down it is they who are
iniquitous if we don't judge by the
gospel we're immoral look at what Allah
says in verse 68 oh people of the book
you stand on not you stand on Nothing
Till You observe the Torah and the
gospel and that which has been sent down
unto you from your lord Jews and
Christians have nothing to stand on
until we obey the Torah and the gospel
and yet our Muslim friends insist either
that we don't have the gospel
contradicting sah 7: 157 or that we have
a corrupted gospel what does the Quran
say about the possibility of changing
Allah's words Surah 18 verse 27 recite
that which has been revealed unto thee
from the book of thy Lord none Alters
his words none Alters his words none
Alters his words and thou will find no
refuge apart from him every dawa guy you
ever meet will tell you that Christians
altered Allah's words what does Allah
say none Alters his
words the Quran even claims that the
Bible is authoritative over Muhammad's
revelations in Surah 10:94 Allah says to
Muhammad so if Thou Art in doubt
concerning that which we have sent down
unto thee ask those who recite the book
before thee those who recite the book
before Muhammad are the people of the
book Jews and Christians Muhammad could
only confirm his Revelations by checking
with Jews and Christians to make make
sure his Revelations line up with our
Revelations now think about this mammad
is trying to convince us that Jesus was
just another Prophet that the Quran is
the word of God and that Islam is the
True Religion but over and over again
the Quran portrays Jesus as greater than
any Prophet including Muhammad the
gospel the scripture that Christians
still have as the inspired preserved
word of God God and the Bible as
authoritative even over Muhammad's
Revelations so the Quran contains
everything a Muslim needs to escape
Islam to recognize Muhammad as a false
prophet and to seek Jesus by going to
the
Bible so why would we think that God has
a hand in all of this well what are the
main options here from a Muslim
perspective Islam is true and Jesus is a
nearly human prophet
but if Islam is true and Jesus is a
merely human Prophet why does the Quran
affirm the inspiration preservation and
authority of scriptures that contradict
the
Quran and why does the Quran portray
Jesus as far greater than any Prophet
the Muslim perspective makes absolutely
no sense this leaves two main non-muslim
perspectives the most common non-muslim
view is that Muhammad was copying
stories he heard with without
understanding the theological
implications of what he was copying in
other words he heard Christians calling
Jesus the word of God and he included
this in the Quran but he didn't know
what it meant and this view has quite a
bit of support in the Quran Surah 25: 4
to5 and the disbelievers say this is not
but a lie that he has fabricated and
another people have helped him in it
they have indeed produced a wrongdoing
and a calumny and they say they are
fables of those of old which he has had
written down and they are recited to him
morning and
evening so the Quran admits that people
during the time of Muhammad were
accusing him of copying other people's
stories and then passing them off as
Revelations Surah 9 verse 61 and a among
them are those who torment the prophet
and say he is an
ear they called Muhammad an ear because
he would believe the stories of anyone
who came to visit him it makes perfect
sense then to think that Muhammad was
copying stories from Christians the
problem with this view is that Muhammad
also felt free to change those stories
to bring them in line with Islam
Muhammad took stories about Adam and
Noah and Abraham and Moses and so on and
he turned Adam and Noah and Abraham and
Moses and so on into devout Muslims so
if Muhammad was altering stories about
various religious figures to make them
sound like devout Muslims why is Jesus
completely unique in the Quran and why
does the Quran point to the Bible to
find the
answers is it a coincidence that
Muhammad's biggest blunders as a false
prophet the things that expose him most
as a false prophet because they
contradict the rest of his Revelations
are verses that point people directly to
Jesus and the Bible doesn't it make more
sense to think that as Muhammad the
Caravan robber was robbing religions of
their teachings and their most important
figures the almighty made sure Muhammad
took some paint packs that would
eventually blow up in his face expose
him as a religion robber and show people
where to go like the lights on the floor
of a plane that guide you to safety if
the plane
crashes what do you think when the Quran
portrays Jesus as completely unique and
when the Quran affirms the inspiration
preservation and authority of the
scriptures that we have is this a happy
accident or did God make sure that
Muhammad included these things in the
Quran to help us guide our Muslim
friends out of Islam and into the
waiting arms of the Risen Lord Jesus
Christ let me know what you think in the
comments but keep in mind that if these
passages about Jesus and the Bible were
inserted into the Quran like paint packs
so that we could lead Muslims out of
Islam we shouldn't take this opportunity
lightly so if you want to help our
Muslim friends see the paint all over
Muhammad's face and to see the trail
that's leading them out of Islam and to
see the truth about Jesus be sure to
watch and take notes on my videos 10
ways Jesus is greater than Muhammad in
the Quran where I show how Jesus is
completely unique in the Quran and what
the Quran really says about the gospel
where I go through every single verse in
the entire Quran that so much as
mentions the gospel to show that there
isn't one word in the Quran that's
critical of the
Gospel play time's over for Muhammad the
religion
robber oh die pack man that stings
[Music]